[Música]
no lo que economía en directo américa de
france24 àngel eran don acompañándolo
como siempre todas las mañanas danny y
se cumplieron finalmente los temores de
europa sobre el suministro del gas ruso
que a pasar finalmente no lo sabremos no
lo sabremos todavía raúl es que el
gasoducto nord stream o no revolvió
después de un mantenimiento pero el
lunes el gigante gazprom anunció que el
suministro bajará a la mitad por
supuestos problemas técnicos y
logísticos que a bruselas rechaza y
atribuye a decisiones políticas lo
cierto es que la reducción del flujo de
gas hacia europa inició hace semanas
concretamente el 4 de junio desde ese
entonces se viene hablando de las
turbinas averiadas en el north stream o
no el kremlin siempre culpó de la
situación a las sanciones occidentales y
para finales de julio el tubo operaba
apenas al 40% de su capacidad ahora
gazprom anuncia que desde el miércoles
el suministro bajará al 20 por ciento de
la capacidad la alemana siemens que es
la encargada del mantenimiento asegura
que la infraestructura está lista para
su uso y que solamente está pendiente
los
documentos de aduana que se necesitan
para permitirle el ingreso a rusia claro
danny y ante todo esto por supuesto
europa ya toma entonces medidas no para
llegar a un acuerdo para reducir este
consumo claro que sí la semana pasada
hubo una propuesta inicial por parte de
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula von der leyen quien había
propuesto una reducción del 15% del
consumo para los 27 países de la unión
europea hasta marzo de 2023 a partir de
agosto que pasaría de voluntaria esta
reducción a vinculante si la situación
se agravaba en ese momento al menos 12
países se opusieron y la iniciativa fue
modificada y finalmente aprobada este
martes el ahorro entonces seguirá siendo
el mismo pero ya no será obligatorio
para algunas naciones o industrias la
medida entonces generó posiciones
divididas
festín santo el 15 por ciento
probablemente no será suficiente dado lo
que han anunciado los rusos una mayor
reducción de sus suministros de gas a
través de nuestro en uno pero es mejor
que no tenerlo creo que la señal que
envía también es importante para
nuestros ciudadanos y para el mundo
no necesitamos ningún límite 11 países
tienen algunos límites cuando se trata
de gas polonia no los tiene y no hay
necesidad de ningún límite ya que los
sitios de almacenamiento están llenos y
tenemos gas que nos ha llegado y de
europa aterrizamos en nuestra región
vamos a venezuela porque parece que la
economía pues está dando signos de luz
de salir un poco a flote tras tantos
años de hundimiento año así es a raúl el
presidente nicolás maduro ya lo había
anunciado había dicho el pasado 13 de
julio que la economía venezolana había
crecido en dos dígitos durante el primer
semestre sin embargo en ese entonces no
precisó la cifra porque dijo que la
labor le correspondía al banco central
venezolano los datos entonces más
recientes no son del banco central
venezolano sino del observatorio
venezolano de finanzas que es un ente
independiente de economistas
dice que la actividad económica del país
aumentó en 12 3% entre enero y junio
esto en comparación con el mismo período
del año pasado cuando se había contraído
en un 28% según los expertos económicos
de este organismo el resultado se debe
por un lado al incremento en la
producción petrolera y también a los
precios también al mayor gasto público y
tal vez la más importante de todas que
hace el fin de la hiperinflación en este
país buenos indicadores económicos dan y
bueno raúl mientras que wall street se
prepara para una apertura a la baja en
pocos minutos después de que wal mart en
rebajar a sus proyecciones de ventas
para este año en europa los mercados
están cautelosos y presentan mínimas
variaciones por lo que pueda pasar con
todo este tema del gas natural entre
tanto las bolsas de asia cerraron mixtas
muy pendientes también de la reunión de
dos días de la reserva federal que
inicia este martes y de la que podrían
salir nuevos aumentos en las tasas de
interés
tania estamos en época de cierre de
cuentas del primer semestre y vamos a
hablar de uno que nos interesa por
supuesto en la inflación y cómo se
comportaron los precios en suramérica en
estos 6 meses hacia el raúl pues mire
hicimos un repaso de cómo se comportó el
índice de precios al consumidor en estos
primeros seis meses del año en algunos
países de suramérica no en todos porque
no tendríamos pues todo el tiempo y
descubrimos que mientras algunas cifras
están bastante elevadas otras registran
datos inflacionarios más reducidos en
comparación con el promedio ahora veamos
mientras que en argentina que junto con
venezuela son los países más
inflacionarios de la región hubo un
aumento de precios del 36 2% entre enero
y junio bolivia que es un país sin
acceso al océano y con un poco más de 11
millones de habitantes pues reportó un
alza del 1,2 por ciento en este mismo
período usted puede ver la brecha es
bastante alta el resto de países que
revisamos como perú brasil que es la
economía más grande de la región
colombia o chile ellos mostraron
ascensos que van del 4% al 7%
dependiendo del país estamos hablando
del aumento acumulado entre enero de
este año y junio